les tensions entre le malaise
mais si regardez là une tâche et
argerich une grosse tâche très
préoccupant ça c'est la partie basse du
diaphragme
on fera jeter vous des lunettes mais
s'il vous plaît le plus docteur qui
d'abord à non mais je suis pas docteur
merde c'est un patient et maîtrise ayé
j'ai un truc hyper grave sortie si
j'aime cette date en prison mais c'est
une urgence jeudi de sortir tout de
suite à mon cabinet pardonnez moi vous
lisiez un gros sentiment de stress c'est
ça je peux rester dernière chez toi ce
soit dur non couché je fais une rupture
d'anévrisme
pour avoir le cerveau un minimum
irrigués pour faire une rupture
d'anévrisme comment ça va j'ai chopé un
petit rhume mais ça va si les
hypocondriaques elle donne ainsi raison
d'un médecin peut-être une bière de quoi
saper qu'à un petit peu de la pire me
l'a dit social la solitude
une fois en couple il me faudra enfin la
paie comportant des banquets qui
marquera cette femme à toutes les femmes
max de testostérone
sarah meier bien
dimitri t'assure c'est la femme de ma
vie je vais te taper vous inquiétez pas
tout va bien je suis mac ça c'est mon
patient quand je dois